chairman script here as chair of the
house fishing game and Marine Resources
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor emergency order 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to the fishing game
and Marine Resources committee executive
session on pending legislation may be
held at any time please note there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe or listen
contemporaneous to this meeting however
in accordance with emergency order I am
confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through Zoom electronic meeting platform
and that the public has access to
contemporan listen and if necessary
participate in the meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar or
through elic calendar on the general
court website the notice of this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
271-3600 or email
HCS
l.st do. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff there on a meeting assisting us
Jennifer FL our
researcher please note that all votes
taken during this meeting shall be done
by ro roll call let's start this meeting
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member
states when each member states their
presence please also State whether
anyone is in the room with you during
meeting and where you're at which is
required by the right to no La uh M
clerk if you could call the
representative con president the clerk
is present representative close present
representative Spain present
representative Howard
Craig
representative representative M
substituting for representative
W uh present in my office an employee
may walk through from time to
time representative here representative
Dy
Smith representative Harvey here
representative flam representative
kitchen representa
King
can
representative
Ean representative R president thank you
representative Egan is present and home
at home in my home in Sugar Hill by
myself representative Ean representative
R representative
shli I am at my residence in Ward one of
conet the village of Penacook and I'm
alone thank you representative Ellis I'm
here in Rochester and I'm alone
clerkes Lang I'm here the off I'm sorry
Mr
chair I didn't get a l thank you uh we
have a roll call of the committee as
being present uh we'll move on and open
up our first public hearing which is on
uh Senate Bill
129 relative to the minimize of
environmental impacts of habitats and
endangered or threatened species and
introduce recognize Senator je
chairman good morning Mr chairman good
morning Senator thank you for being here
today and the floor is yours sir uh
thank you very much pleasure uh to be
with you and all your committee members
for the record Jeb Bradley from
wolfboro um pleased to be the SP coner
of Senate Bill 129 it passed the Senate
on a bipartisan vote of
21-3 the background of the bill is as
follows there was a um court case in New
Hampshire that changed the way that
alteration of terrain permits were
judged by both the Department of
Environmental Services and uh fishing
game and a very rigid reading of the
statute ensued that basically has
created a log Jam a backlog uh whatever
you want to call it of alteration of
terrain permits and alteration of
terrain um permits are for 100,000
square feet and larger projects um this
backlog of Permitting has um really had
a negative impact on contractors on home
build builders on projects throughout
New Hampshire as um the very rigid
interpretation of um Wildlife issues was
different from the way these permits
have been adjudicated in the past and so
I was approached by the contractors and
the homebuilders I worked with Dees and
fishing game uh to come up with the
language that is in the copath last
version of Senate Bill 129 and as I said
it had an overwhelming bipartisan vote
in the Senate so uh Mr chairman if I can
just briefly walk through what the bill
does um I would appreciate that and I
think the word appreciate is perhaps the
most important word in Senate Bill 129
and you see it first on line
seven the way the current statute reads
um with regard to um the way these
permits for conservation of endangered
or threatened species um reads right now
and was subsequently interpreted by the
court they do not
jeopardize and so by adding the word
appreciably it m it mirrors the way that
first of all the endangered spe Species
Act um has been written appreciably
jeopardized and it returns if you will
to the way that these permits have been
judged um in the past before this court
case and then it goes on on lines 9
through 11 um requiring such action
designed to avoid and minimize harm and
again appreciably jeopardize the
continued existence of
species and it calls for rules being
adopted by the executive director of
fishing game uh to implement this new
statute and through that Ru making
process then um all entities will be
able to participate I think this is a
balanced approach um to the need and
quite frankly the contractors and the
homebuilders and all of the jobs related
to those Industries have signed off on
this
legislation um in conversations and if
you will negotiations with environmental
groups led by uh The Nature
Conservancy uh sections two and three in
the bill were added so that in the event
that there was a need for mitigation of
wildlife impacts similar in the way that
road projects and wetlands um can be
done a mitigation fund would be set up
um for unavoidable impacts to Wildlife
or wildlife habitat and so that's broken
down into um species that are
threatened um and
endangered uh versus those that are not
threatened and endangered and funding if
there are unavoidable impacts to go into
you know both of those funds in sections
two and three again signed off on by uh
the entities that would like contractors
Etc um have to you know
potentially um pay funds into this Fund
in order for a project to go
forward uh the if you look on page two
there is legislative oversight uh with a
report by October
21 uh October 1 of 2022 and every year
after that so the legislature will have
a role to play in looking at how these
funds are utilized so in a nutshell um I
think that this is a um approach that
has gotten broad support it's absolutely
essential if we are going to protect the
jobs of hardworking men and women in the
construction industry of New Hampshire
that this bill go forward as
expeditiously as possible as those
permits are backed up in this Log Jam
created by the court case so with that
Mr chairman I thank you and would be
happy to answer any
questions thank you senat I appreciate
that great introduction and I'll
recognize represent seems to have a
stand up for question thank you Mr
chairman and Senator Bradley it's always
ni seeing you if only remotely um I I
have the first question I have is you
mentioned Senator that that word
appreciably uh came out of the uh
Endangered Species Act of
1973 was that word in the original act
or was that part of the us uh congress's
amendment of The Endangered Species Act
in the last Congress
uh I don't know the answer to that
question representative shirtliffe um it
I was told um as we work through the
bill by all sides that appreciably is
the um word that's used in The
Endangered Species Act so when um and
how it might have been placed there I
can't answer for you thank you followup
Mr chairman absolutely good thank you Mr
chairman thank you Senator
um this bill will give sole authority to
the executive director of the fishing
game to determine what projects may
cause an unavoidable impact on wildlife
and
habitat so um under the legislation the
executive director would have to adopt
rules um and then as these permits are
adjudicated obviously Wildlife interests
are something that the fishing game
department looks at but this is a Dees
related permit so there's um
participation by both
agencies and one last followup Mr
chairman absolutely sir thank you uh Mr
chairman um not having a life I actually
read the Supreme Court's decision in
remanding warehous or uh V us Fish and
Wild life back to the fifth circuit and
their concern was on the definition of
habitat and critical habitat and uh that
the fif circuit failed to distinguish
between the two do you know if in New
Hampshire we do have a defin definition
in law uh between what is a habitat and
what is a critical habitat uh that would
be a question I think best reserved for
um the fishing game folks that I'm
assuming ass uming are going to testify
on this bill or Dees um
again I would just
stress how important it is
for um you know all of the contractors
and the jobs that they represent and
they will be testifying I'm sure today
also that we have this balanced
approach um to these Wildlife issues as
part of alteration of Rin fit a um
approach that is uh what's happening
right now it is going to um
upend uh the ability of hardworking men
and women and their employers to be able
to do this kind of work um as the Log
Jam just gets worse and worse and worse
thank you Senator thank you Mr
chairman uh the Mr s from Michigan will
be up next to talk so for future
questions representative dville you have
a question you unmute yourself go
ahead uh thank you Mr chairman uh this
isn't a a question for Senator Bradley
Senator Bradley thank you for showing up
today uh I can hear everyone who's
remote much clearer than I can hear
people who are in the fishing game
committee is it possible for them to
raise the uh volume for the people uh
for the mic phones in the fishing game
committee
room so uh thank you for that uh
Jennifer can we see if we can get it to
come down and maybe raise the gain on
the uh on the outbound speaker for the
now any uh Mr
chair who is that that is representative
Ean my video has fallen out so I've
rejoined on just through the telephone
so I just wanted to make sure that they
record was aware that I am attending and
only by phone so my apologies so
represent that's fine if you decide to
EXA anything though you'll need to have
video uh for the exact I will make an
effort to get it back great thank you um
representative
Harvey thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Senator Bradley so um I understand
that some of these definitions would be
um handled through rules and Ru making
of fish a game but is there in this bill
place uh if you look
representative online 10 11 and
12 um shall be defined in rules adopted
by the executive director uh that
obviously means that the fishing game
director will have to bring rules to
Jael car
so that word shall is what you're
pointing
to the word shall I think is pretty
intent so does that also apply to a
appreciable um well if you look again on
lines 9 through um 12 it
it says for the purpose of this
statute then in quotes appreciably
jeopardize the continued existence of
such species end quote shall be defined
in rules adopted so that's exactly
what the intent of sener Bill 129 is is
to ensure that um you know the executive
director pursue rules take them to Jael
card through the normal rule approval
you representative
mcon your hand is right thank you Mr
chairman uh Senator Bradley nice to see
you they and thank you for bringing this
for forward because the word Log Jam is
is a kind word that's happening to
contractors up here and to the people
that are issuing those permits or trying
to um I'm always and I so I applaud what
you're doing here the uh my concern is
um rule making and I'm hoping we'll hear
from fishing game later that they're
ready to roll this out quick because I I
would use the word crippling at this
point uh to what's happening out there
and uh I'm I'm hoping we'll be able to
hear that if they if we can get this
past that uh this will be something that
can happen sooner than later and thank
you for your efforts
is there a question was there well I
would just chime in um obviously uh
representative mcon is very familiar
with the um alteration of terrain
permitting process he's exactly right I
was probably being kind when I said it
was uh Log Jam as opposed to crippling
and um it would be my hope that this
would be a top priority to get in front
of Jael car
thank thank you sir any questions from
the
room thank you Mr chairman morning Santa
Bradley
um I understand by reading the bill that
it would be up to the executive director
of fishing gain to decide U what habitat
would be critical I'm questioning um
de's uh um role would Dees be
responsible for deciding what was
appreciable because they are the ones
who ultimately do the permit or am I
confused there so my understanding of
the way that the permitting process
works alteration of terrain is a Dees
permitting process but as part of that
process they consult with the fish and
game dep Department about critical
wildlife and wildlife habitat so um
there is a dual role if you will but the
way the statute is constructed it's the
executive director of fishing game that
has to promate and bring the rules
before Jael car on the habitat
issue thanks Senator I'm just going to
make a statement very because I did
speak with the executive director offici
regarding the number of permits I'm
pending um as of middle of March there
were a little over 85 permits I believe
that were pending fishing game taking
action they've since taken action on
over half of those um and and and dealt
with them um and they're move the rest
they're supposed to have done within the
next month or so and move those permits
ahead so just so and I'm sure we can ask
represent Mr serson about this from
fishing game but um just so you
understand what all that fog Jam looked
like they talking about was 90 building
permits throughout the state that were
held up that required an aot and as part
of that aot they needed fishing game
involvement and fishing game because of
that law was waiting to wasn't quite
sure so I you have a question for the
senator um so my question for the
senator is Senator if I understand this
bill right and what this bill is doing
is taking a process that um we've had in
the past that were that didn't have good
sides and good boundaries around it and
that's exactly what we're doing we're
putting some rules some sides and
boundaries in this case of when we're
dealing with the money aspect of it um
we're actually creating a fund now that
will allow for this money to go into the
fund um to be able to offset and and use
for uh Rehabilitation of of habitat that
is that my understanding of the bill is
that correct yeah that I mean that is
correct and unfortunately due to the
court case
the process for adjudicating these
permits is I think
you know representative makoni said it
best it's it's crippling it's off the
rails and a lot of jobs are at stake so
by the process that's outlined in Senate
Bill 129 with you know the balance of
protecting habitat mitigation efforts
but also a much more um prompt
adjudication of aot permits um will
allow you know this Log Jam backlog
whatever you want to call it um to you
know get worked through the system and
not have this problem hopefully in the
future these permits um were adjudicated
in a much more timely fashion before the
court case now um these big projects I
mean you know when they're being
financed um jobs are at stake timing is
everything and um to have this kind of
delay
uh with this many jobs at stake and you
know the economy of our state is so
dependent on construction to me is
unacceptable and I think Senate Bill 129
strikes the appropriate balance thank
you sen the representative
how thank you Mr chairman thank you
Senator Bradley for taking my
question do you do you know by any
chance what
year that this perent process went into
effect originally I think the court case
was in
2019 but
um it's fairly recent I believe it was
2019 but others can probably better
answer
that okay because I remember the
determining process from 20 years ago
and it seemed like it was a lot longer
before
that follow up for second question
absolutely followup thank you Mr um now
this
this bill will actually increase fees
for
applicants um if there
are
um if there if there are unavoidable
impacts there uh could be funds paid for
mitigation but remember um you know what
I have indicated all along the and
you'll hear this testimony from the home
builders and contractors that this is a
cost for them of doing business and the
the time that permits sit on people's
desk
because
they take so much longer now to review
is so much more
costly and has so much more of an impact
on jobs than you know the uh mitigation
funds or the fee cost the this is a
acceptable cost of doing business so
don't take it from me um that that's the
case ask them that question because
that's the answer that um they
Senate one follow up to one still we
have eight
speakers we have eight speakers that are
still ping including the there is
somebody from the Hampshire Home my my
question is on will it be a sliding
scale for that fee or is a violation of
set fee no matter how
severe uh that would be a question
better asked of uh the
Departments okay thank
you any further questions
fortive representative love go ahead
thank
about all the paperwork and stuff I
don't see anything
forp I I apologize I only heard a little
bit of that question I'll rephrase so
the question is that um from
representative love is that there's
going to be a cost efficient game to go
out do inspections and stuff and there
doesn't seem there any way in this bill
for the suspicion game to recoup that
labor cost that'll be added to that is
that is there supposed to be a way of
doing that um again that would be a
Mason any further
questions great thank you sen very much
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee thank
you so next up will be uh Mr Paul
leison
thank thank you Mr chairman I believe
that I'm unmuted is PA Sanderson the
legal coordinator of the fish and game
department I want to thank Senator
Bradley for his introduction of this
bill and his attempt to answer the vast
majority of questions that have been
posed uh I really don't have very much
to add other than my ability to answer
some of the questions that have been
asked by members of the committee to
this point uh and with the permission of
the chair I would attempt to do those
right now absolutely go ahead thank you
uh moving to representative shift's
questions uh one of the things I want to
uh point out to folks is that the
Federal in um Endangered Species Act is
the federal endangered Species Act and
that's administered by the US fish and
wildlife service we're talking here RSA
2112a which is the state equivalent
where the department a ficient game is
administering a state list of threatened
and endangered species it is somewhat
different uh so what we're trying to do
here is to move the standards under the
state act to become much closer to those
contained in the federal act they don't
have to be absolutely identical but what
we're trying to do is move it closer so
that when these matters are adud udated
in our state courts there is an entire
body of federal law Around The
Endangered Species Act that our courts
can use for guidance as to the meanings
of these critical terms including
appreciably the meaning of habitat the
meaning of critical habitat which have
been extensively litigated at the
federal level and in fact are the
subject of federal regulations which I
cited to you in my testimony so that is
the reason why uh these words have been
proposed and why these words are
important uh as to representative
Harvey's question regarding rules I must
tell you that these particular rules are
in fact of the very highest priority
there is a working group between uh fish
and game department and the Department
of Environmental Services that meets on
a weekly basis to propose changes to
rules to try to implement these new
standards uh in fact we have already
drafted
uh some proposed changes which went to a
an unusual joint pre- rulemaking hearing
process where we've already sought
comment not only from the regulated
Community but also from the
environmental Community uh that was
conducted and we've received that and
we're moving on towards our next draft
so that we can in fact uh propose rules
in the very near
future uh with respect to uh questions
that really been asked by representative
mccon and Howard and love regarding
resources at the Department of Fish and
Game um understand that there are no
fees that come to the Department of
fishing game for the conduct of wildlife
assessments and
reviews and so therefore uh we have been
performing these tasks with existing
staff using uh resources from our
non-game program and also from federal
grants we do not receive any portion of
any uh application fee that has been
filed by an applicant with any other
state permitting agency and so are
resources an issue yes however this is
not a secret and this is something that
has been extensively discussed not only
with the governor's office but also with
h and Senate budget writers and that
process
continues uh with respect to uh
representative Lam's question as to
whether Dees would be the agency that
would decide what is the meaning of
appreciably jeopardized the answer to
that is no that would not be conducted
in their rules it would be conducted in
the rules of the fish and game
department because these uh rules that
we would be proposing affect not only
Department of Environmental Services but
all other state agencies uh that may
come before us with regard to requests
for permits or requests for changes in
land use on land that they own that
could include Department of trans
Transportation the Department of Natural
and cultural resources and
others uh I think uh that that answers
all of the questions which
representatives have posed to this point
and I'd be happy to answer any other
questions that any other representative
would like to
pose uh Vice chairman Abul has a
question for you go ahead Vice thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr Senator taking
my question is there a big difference
when it comes to the list of federal
inventer species and the state is there
a very big difference between those two
list um thank you representative the
lists of uh Federal endangered species
and state
dangered I'll get it endangered species
they are different uh they are already
contained in rules that have been
promulgated by this department uh they
are different species they're not the
same and the two programs are not
administered in lockstep we certainly
cooperate with the US fish and wildlife
service with regard to anything that is
on the federal threatened and endangered
species list and we are working in
concert with them often on state
endangered species but the two sets of
different representative chair Mr chair
Mr chair this is representative Ean with
a question when when I'm allowed sure
give you right
after thank you Mr chairman thank you
counselor I didn't quite get an answer
to my one question to Senator Bradley
and that was regarding the word applic
applicability um was that add was that
part of the original Endangered Species
Act of
1973 or was that part of the revisions
Implement to last year in the combined
Federal
Regulations uh thank you for your
question representative it was not in
the original it was part of the changes
last year thank you
councelor
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Sanderson for taking my question absence
the word appreciably on page one line
nine would you see the agency supporting
this
legislation in other words your question
is if that word were not part of the
bill as as it reported out and
ultimately passed uh the answer to that
is the language that is ultimately
chosen by the legislature is the
language that we will implement and we
will go through the rulemaking process
with the uh that word in place or that
word not in place and we're going to be
accepting comment from uh not only uh
legislators but also the public as we
adopt our rules in an effort to try to
improve the
situation thank you followup Mr chair
absolutely go
ahead does
that word make the ru making process for
fishing game more difficult to make
decisions
clearly uh thank you representative in
that regard the word is important
because if you are in fact a proponent
of change on a particular piece of
landscape the word appreciably helps to
modify and understand the efforts that
you're trying to make as you alter that
landscape in the absence of the word
appreciably uh other people may argue
that any changes to the landscape in
fact are harmful to threaten an
endangered species who may be present on
that landscape what it does there is no
ultimate resolution here on each
particular parcel there is a balance
between the impact to threaten an
endangered species and the impact of
private property rights that is the very
difficult job that staff of our
department as well as staff of other
state have in reviewing every particular
individual
project
represent no thank you Mr Sanderson as
always you are um well educating us on
the Comm fishing game committee thank
you
sir thank you Mr chairman um Mr
Sanderson um so the chair just told us
that um the number of cases that had
been backlogged and I um let's see I
wrote down 85 there were 85 permits that
have been backlogged
that action has been taken on over half
of them and the rest will be taken up
shortly so
um
would what caused that backlog I I
understand the court case is an issue
but um I if if since there was a court
case would hiring more Personnel to take
care of these permits would that have
helped with that
backlog in lie of SD 129 I guess thank
you representative
um as a result of the court case that
has been referred to which uh came down
from the New Hampshire Supreme Court in
November of 2019 Department of
Environmental Services enacted a rule in
uh the spring of 2020 which made a
fundamental change and that fundamental
change was that instead of past practice
which had been sending only those
particular projects that had uh a
demonstrated impact through the natural
Heritage database over to this
department for review all applications
to the aot program came over to us for
review so so that number and increase uh
in workload is what has caused timing
because no new resources were available
to be uh set to the problem so uh
changes that have occurred recently have
been a return to past practice saying
that we will review projects that have
uh a demonstrated contact through the
natural heritage database and not review
every single project that comes through
the aot program that has materially
assisted in reducing the amount of time
uh that it takes to handle the number of
received so with those changes in mind
then um and it seems like you're moving
forward through these uh backlogged
permits with those changes in mind
why do you foresee another backlog in
the
future thank you representative we we
foresee another issue going forward
because there is simply more development
that is occurring throughout our state
uh I would like to refer you back to
Senator Bradley's comments okay uh that
there are in fact many more
opportunities uh that the private sector
is using to attempt to develop uh
property they're doing so because there
is a housing shortage in our state
they're doing so uh because uh there are
tremendous needs throughout communities
for development of other types of space
and so as development increases more and
more Parcels are impacted more and more
uh will need review through the aot and
other programs and so we do expect that
the overall uh request for uh reviews
and input will increase because of the
general economic
environment thank
s seeing none we'll move on to the next
speaker which will I'm going to move now
to our public members uh members of the
public so first up is Joan O'Brien Joan
if you could raise your hand so we can
great
Brian are you there hi Mr chairman this
is Jim O'Brien um not Joan O'Brien Jim
O'Brien I'm the director of external
Affairs for The Nature Conservancy in
New Hampshire um and I'm here today
going to speak on behalf of the nature
conservancy but also five other
conservation organizations in the state
and so I'll name them um so the New
Hampshire Association of conservation
missions New Hampshire aabon Society for
protection in New Hampshire Forest New
Hampshire Rivers
Council um and the Appalachian Mountain
Club so thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak and I've sent in um
a letter uh a letter of support for the
bill um that I hope you have received if
not I'll speak very briefly to some of
the the points in the letter um so first
I want to thank uh Dees fishing game um
we've been working with them over the
course of the past year or so on um a
lot of what you just heard about the ru
making that's been ongoing um on this
issue and also thank Senator Bradley um
we worked with him and his colleagues in
the Senate on some of the language in
the bill that you have in front of you
um so in we we are here to provide some
testimony and support of Senate Bill
129 um we support um the concept of the
bill um and I think as Senator Bradley
spoke you know we um very supportive of
the the mitigation fund um and how it
it's established in the bill um in
section two um I do want to note I know
we've you you've talked and heard
testimony on on the term appreciably um
we do um I think as a an conservation
Community we don't we oppose I guess is
the right way to say it um the inclusion
of that word on page one uh line nine of
the
legislation um we think that that
including the term in the statute only
confuses the issue and may lead to
increased litigation um over the course
of time for Department decisions um as
Mr Sanderson just said the department is
undergoing um a rul making process um
they had a hearing last month um where
these terms um like jeopardizing the
continued existence of species are being
defined we feel that that's a better
place um um with the wildlife biologists
and the experts um with the Department
of fishing game to be making um
qualifiers Around The Endangered Species
Act and and not leaving it up to the
legislature um to do that we we think
the rulemaking process is the proper
place um for those terms um to be
defined and to be um executed and I'll
just say on the rulemaking side we we
are very supportive um and and very
pleased that fishing game is moving
forward with with rules um on on
enforcement and decision-making Around
The Endangered Species Act um you know
currently there are no rules um and so
um while I know there's been a court
case you know fishing game doesn't have
any rules for for defining terms like
critical habitat um jeopardizing
continued existence of species or even
how they go about making decisions on
which impacts are so great that um you
know avoidance or minimization or um
payment into a mitigation fund would be
appropriate so we just feel that um the
rulle making charges both in section one
and section two of this bill are really
important um we understand that there is
movement on rul making but I think the
legislature um putting in this statute
that the expectation is that within a
year these rules will be executed and
moving forward we feel is the push that
the department needs um because we have
been working um not saying there's been
anything wrong but you know this this
permitting process has been in place now
for for years and the department still
doesn't have any rules that that show us
or the public what's guiding their
decisions on what's appropriate and
what's
not um with that as I mentioned I did
send um our testimony so if if um for
more information you could read that I'm
happy to answer any questions from the
committee thank you so
much any questions from Mr
Brien represent go ahead thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr O'Brien uh Mr
O'Brien I got your letter and I
appreciate um you and the other groups
sending that to us on the word
appreciable if the bill were amended to
remove that word would you and your
colleagues find the bill far more I mean
able and um I I feel the word
appreciable is like Beauty the
definitions in the eyes of the beholder
so would you think it removing that word
would improve the bill um thank you
representative for the question um I I
think the the short answer is yes um you
know when I when I leave when I think
about the the term that that that
appreciably is is um is qualifying I
mean it's jeopardizing the continued
existence of a species and so it's hard
to think of of putting a qualifier in
front of jeopardizing the continued
existence you either are doing it or
you're not um and and so to us anyway um
defining the term jeopardizing the
continued existence of a species makes
more sense than trying to qualify it
before you even get to a definition and
and the definition um in federal statute
for jeopardizing the continued existence
of a species as well as the Draft rules
that fishing game put out
um uh for comment a month ago includes
the words appreciably but it it it isn't
qualifying jeopardizing the continued
existence of a species and I could read
the paragraph um just I hope that it
clarifies a little bit so this is the
federal
definition um the federal definition is
jeopardizing the continued existence of
means to engage in an action that
reasonably would be expected directly or
indirectly to reduce appreciatively so
there's a term to reduce appreciably the
likelihood of both the survival and
recovery of a listed species and so
anyway I this is that was a very long
rambling answer to your good question
representative but I I do think we would
um I think removing that term um we
would support that and our hope is that
through the ru making process the
fishing game has already said they're
undertaking um the concerns around that
would be would would have a public
process that could then be defined in a
more clear way
thank you thank you Mr
mrri there being none thank you we move
on to our next speaker which will be uh
Miss Ralph
Valentine
of good morning Mr chairman can you hear
me I can sir go ahead sir thank you very
much
uh thank you chairman Lang and members
of of the committee and thank you
senator Bradley for the bill my name is
Ralph Valentine I am the chair of the
public policy Committee of the New
Hampshire commercial investment board of
realtors I am here today testifying on
behalf of 7,000 plus realtor members in
the state in support of Senate Bill
129 the bill ultimately surrounds the
state application the aot application
and each time a business owner homeowner
or developer disturbs about two acres
the permit
required as we know the current permit
requires the applicant to report on any
impact on endangered
species the legislation comes in Wake of
the Supreme Court case placing
additional burdens on the applicant to
have fishing game validate what is
already reported by the
applicant prior to that case the process
was about 6 to 10 weeks and according to
conversations that time is almost
doubled the legislation and the
rulemaking should provide the balance
that we wish to weigh between private
property rights and Environmental
Protection without the bill new job
creation will be delayed whether whether
they are temporary construction jobs a
permanent jobs which are the result of
business
expansion and more important without
this bill there's a delay and a cost of
delay of the entitlement process will
exasperate the housing shortage so we do
support this bill uh in its Uh current
form thank you thank you any questions
from Mr
Valentin seeing none thank you Mr
Valentine appreciate that next next up
Hampshire
she she went to the top I was looking
thanks again M yourself hello good
morning good morning we can hear you
hello you can hear me now we can very
good yeah it asked me to unmute a little
box so good morning yes Suzanne forer
I'm coordinator of a Grassroots group um
in Milford uh called Brocks
environmental citizens I'm here to ask
you to oppose s
sp229 because it would weaken
protections afforded to wild species of
animals who are already in Jeopardy the
most Jeopardy
the bill if you look at it begins with
this powerful directive and I quote all
other state departments and agencies to
the extent possible consistent with
their authorities and responsibilities
shall assist and cooperate with the
executive director in the furtherance of
the purposes of this chapter for the
conservation of endangered or threatened
species
unquote and what is the statute's main
purpose it's found in section three of
the law and it reads quote species of
wildlife normally occurring within this
state which may be found to be in
Jeopardy should be accorded such
protection as is necessary to maintain
and enhance their numbers
unquote but this bill allows harm to the
species that are already in Jeopardy so
how can anyone expect that the species
will do okay being
harmed by by the way minimized harm is
just another way of saying that the harm
is
controlled
regulated the harm that would be
authorized under this bill would be
regulated and minimized but it would not
be
harmless so fishing game recently
defined harm in a definition that is
tailored to fit the types of harm that
are experienced by the endangered
species it's harm that happens to them
as a result of Permitting decisions made
by departments like the Department of
Environmental Services fishing game's
definition of harm is this and I
quote harm means any act which actually
kills or injures individuals of a
threatened or endangered species or
which acts to destroy degrade or
adversely modify the habitat supporting
the species by interfering with breeding
hibernation reproduction feeding
Sheltering migration or overwintering
behaviors that are a part of its normal
or traditional life cycle and that are
essential to its survival and
perpetuation unquote that's from fishing
game that's the definition of harm and
that is exactly the kind of harm that
this bill would allow to happen it would
be harm to the house habitat supporting
the species by interfering with the
animals behaviors that are essential to
their survival and very important
perpetuation of their own species
remember the purpose of the 2112a to
maintain and enhance their
populations a last important Point
although you didn't hear it uh mentioned
by um attorney Sanderson for fishing
game the fishing game
department um The Fishing Game
Commission of the department they voted
to support s sp229 but I want you to
keep something in mind that is the Fish
and Game Commission Fish and Game
Commission we're not talking about fish
and game um the commission is not known
as the fishing game and non-game and
endangered Wildlife Commission where is
their
expertise it isn't there you should have
heard directly from the non-game and
endangered Wildlife program program on
what they think this bill does to
endangered Wildlife instead you heard
from attorney Sanderson and he said an
awful lot about development and balance
he did not say an awful lot about the
purpose of 2112a and protecting the
species so I hope you will continue to
support the act as it is it is a good
act it is strong okay and I hope you
will reject S
sp29 I thank you for
listening thank you m any questions from
this
morning seeing none in the room seeing
none in Zoom I appreciate thank you very
much next up is um Kurt
Arenberg hello chairman Lang members of
the committee my name is Kurt aronberg I
am the uh state
director uh New Hampshire state director
for the Humane Society of the United
States um you do have written testimony
I believe from us um from our affiliate
the Humane Society Wildlife Land Trust
formed in 1993 the trust is an affiliate
of the Humane Society of the United
States and uh protects over 21,000 acres
in 32 States including over 1,000 acres
in New Hampshire I appreciate the time
I'll try to be brief just to sum up um
while we
support this the concept of the bill we
believe vital changes are needed so that
the original intent of the legislation
is fulfilled if passed Senate Bill 129
would allow state agencies such as the
Department of Environmental Services to
authorize development projects that
could cause harm to Wildlife this is a
bill designed to speed up the
authorization process of development
permit applications that are backed up
for review by the New Hampshire Fish and
Game department but rather than choose
to allow possible destruction of
wildlife
habitat the uh Department should be
hiring more staff to carefully review
permit applications ultimately this bill
would legalize harm to threatened and
endangered Wildlife species that is
prohibited by existing
law as it stands there are no
administrative rules or other public
documents that establish a clear process
or criteria for the director of fishing
game to reach conclusions under RSA
2112a it also does not require the
fishing game department undertake a
rulemaking process to define the terms
the fishing game department must develop
rules to clearly show how they Define
critical habitat how they will decide if
projects avoid impacts to wildlife
habitats and how they will determine the
penalty when Wildlife harm is
done um that's our position on this bill
I'm happy to uh take any questions thank
you there any questions Mr
arber seeing none in the room seeing
none online thank you Mr Amber
appreciate it very much next up is Gary
abot Gary if you're on the screen can
hand thank you uh chairman Lang and
committee members of the fish and game
committee uh thank you for this
opportunity my name is Gary Abbott I'm
the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I'm here today in full support
of Senate Bill
129 and I would like to fill in some
blanks I know uh Senator Bradley did an
excellent job answering questions but I
wanted to uh talk a little bit about the
reason for this statute
change we had been uh I'm talking from
an applicant's perspective I represent
General Contractors I represent sand and
gravel and developers who do large
projects the the the prior in
2019 uh we had a process in which uh you
would file for a alteration of terrain
permit you would go through the
dees if you would end up with a National
Heritage database hit you would be
referred to fishing game fishing game
would then do a review of that hit which
only meant a smaller percentage of those
alteration of terrain permits went to
fishing
game now that doesn't mean in 2019 I
wasn't in director n noro's office
looking for rules and guidance because
some of those permits got held up but it
was a very small percentage so you have
to understand that process in that
process we use pretty much the
terminology that's in this proposed Bill
the fishing game department would ask
developers to minimize or um avoid
impacts to these wildlife habitats what
is the language in this that avoid and
minimize just wasn't in this statute
this statute was written
more than 20 years ago the court case
highlighted that the statute needed to
come up to what we were doing prior to
2019 and the court
case the other language that you're been
talking about is this appreciably and I
want to talk about that if you remove
that word there will be more court cases
in my opinion because it will say Do not
jeopardize it will not give the fishing
game the leniency that they currently
have and that they had in the past
regarding asking developers to uh
minimize the impacts uh that are
currently exist so it would have a very
bad impact that is why this bill fits
with the fishing game and Dees updating
their rules the other thing that seems
to be missing from the conversation from
a
developers we supported uh the temporary
rules proposed by Dees back in January
of last year we then even supported uh
the rules in June that really caused the
backlog of
permits part of those rules in June
asked the developer to hire a wildlife
biologist to do the work the
investigation on projects I never when I
agreed to supporting those rules thought
it would be every permanent I thought it
would only be those that had some kind
kind of impact or some kind of
recognition of a threatened and
endangered species on the project but
instead it became all the
projects the developer assumed the
financial responsibility to hire those
Wildlife biologists and still submitted
in which most permits by dees are a
90day turnaround turned into months and
months so you can understand my position
as the vice president of the assoc
General Contractors I started to receive
uh not only from those that have
applications in those contractors who
hope to start those projects this spring
saying what's going on so from our
perspective we need this legislation
pass to make it clearer to what we were
doing in
2019 to make sure that there's not a new
interpretation of much
stricter and part two is rules and I
really want to I Really appreciate what
Dees and fishing game have done doing
the pre- rulemaking hearing I know there
was a lot of comments we wrote uh our
comments at what those rules should look
like and what changes in their draft
proposal we look forward to working with
them but I think what you have to
recognize is this statute is really so
fishing game the director has the
ability to do some judgment calls on
those projects that have wild uh
endangered and threatened species
I think representative schliff asked a
good question about habitat because I
think that's part of the new broad uh
interpretation if there is no uh
endangered species but the habitat could
be good there's some gray area hopefully
through the rul making process we can
clarify that I don't think it has to all
be in the statute so I asked that the
fishing game committee passed this bill
as it was passed by the Senate it has
been worked on by by a number of groups
as you already heard it's been worked on
with Dees uh fishing game and even the
Attorney General's office I wanted to
put that in we have been working on this
bill for the last six months in the
sense that something needs to be
fixed this seems to do it I would not
remove any of the language or change it
trust me appreciably did not start out
as that word we had many other words
that were tried to be used and that was
the best word we could find so with that
I would end my testimony and answer any
questions and thank you thank you Mr are
there any questions for Mr ra
representative Harvey thank you Mr chair
um so did I hear you correctly when you
say not everything has to be in
legislation that some of it could be in
rules and if I heard you correctly then
why wouldn't this bill and its
definitions be in rules and not in
legislation
I I I actually answered the same
question before the Senate the fishing
game and Dees have to comply with
whatever the legislation says so this
being in the statute uh clearly gives
the directive of what the legislative
intent I don't think 20 years ago we
were talking about avoid and minimize
those have things that have progressed
over time so we really do need it in
statute but there 's a lot of
clarification appeals process a lot of
things that have to be done in rules
that don't end up in statute but I think
this is the guideline and it's clear to
me if you do not if you just have do not
jeopardize there'll be a lot more court
cases saying any little thing can't be
uh uh you you you can't minimize it or
uh avoid it so that's really the issue
that that we have but don't get confused
I think the statute does guide the
agencies in their Ru making so this is
very
important any other questions from Mr
ad see none online see none in the room
thank you Mr ad for your testimony
appreciate it very much thank you next
up is Ari Pollock Ari if you're there if
you can raise your hand we go Ari you
should be able to unmute yourself go
ahead good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee are you able to hear me
I can sir go ahead super uh my name is
arri pollock I'm an attorney practicing
with the law firm of Gallagher Callahan
and Garrell and I'm appearing before you
this morning as a registered lobbyist
for the New Hampshire homebuilders
Association the Home Builders
Association includes uh residential uh
Builders and remodelers across the state
of New Hampshire and we support Senate
Bill 129 as was amended and passed by
the Senate the bill addresses a critical
permitting backlog that is threatening
Land Development and economic growth
across the state as a 20 plusy year New
Hampshire land use attorney and a
longtime lobbyist for the New Hampshire
Home Builders I understand and
appreciate the need for balance in
environmental uh and development policy
and when that uh when matters swing too
far towards protection uh projects that
are critical to housing jobs and the
economy suffer and vice versa when
matters swing too far away from
protection our natural environment
suffers and as I'm sure all of you on
this committee are aware neither extreme
is desirable and this bill addresses a
real and Urgent situation where the
pendulum has swung too far to one
extreme um prior speakers have covered a
lot of the material I had intended to
address and so I'd like to move quickly
to some of the discussion points uh that
were raised this morning the question
about whether or not it would be prudent
to remove the word appreciably before or
within do not jeopardize uh I think that
would be a tremendous mistake um do not
jeopardize led to litigation which led
to an interim rule which led to a
critical backlog we know how that
language was interpreted we know what
that interpretation caused what this
bill does is provide a very important
legislative reset uh a rebalancing if
you will of how that pendulum swings
over time and puts it back in a place
where environmental concerns and
economic concerns can again move forward
together it restates the policy and
hopefully leads the next time the court
reinterprets legislative intent to an
intent to a more modified more balanced
more results oriented landscape as Mr
Abbott was just talking about the uh
Reliance on the natural Heritage Bureau
database used to perform this function
for us it used to either generate a
quote unquote hit for sensitive species
listed threatened endangered species or
not a hit and that was something of a
triage system for whether or not you
needed to have a discussion with the
professionals at fishing game if you had
a hit you had something to discuss if
you didn't have a hit you didn't have
anything to discuss and you proceeded
with your engineering discussion with
the professionals at the Department of
Environmental Services on your
alteration of terrain
engineering um the word
appreciably installs that triage into
the statute it's a legislative statement
of policy as to whether or not there is
something to discuss whereas The Fallout
from the litigation said everything has
to be discussed let's do a wildlife
study on every every case uh or every
permit application rather and let's send
every permit application to fishing game
with that study and let's wait for
everything to be reviewed and sent back
and of course the result was a
tremendous backlog way too much work to
process and way too much delay for
contractors who can't commit to projects
can't hire their Workforce uh and can't
of course uh deliver the projects that
our economy and our housing uh industry
needs uh and our Workforce needs so I
think it would be a big mistake uh to
remove the word appreciably it modifies
do not jeopardize in a way that is
responsible but also returns us to some
balance and uh the notion that uh policy
can be set in rulemaking policy is set
at the state house and all of you were
elected to make those determinations for
your constituency and for the state
rules uh must fit Within statutes and I
know you all appreciate that difference
and distinction um it would be un
unfortunate if that word were removed um
there's already been one case and I
think it's quite likely there'll be more
and that word will be important if the
court is again asked to interpret the
language in this law um with that I'll
end my testimony uh and simply ask uh
for uh your support on this bill which
comes with a sense of urgency as as you
know the well notwithstanding last
week's snowstorm the weather is
improving and we are in the midst of the
construction season uh and jobs are at
stake and on the line so there is really
a sense of urgency to get this bill uh
through the state house into the
governor's desk and the Home Builders
Association certainly requests uh your
support thank you very much and happy to
take questions thank you AR are there
any questions for Mr
PA seeing none in the room seeing none
online uh thank you Mr Po for your
testimony thank you is there anybody
else El attends to the meeting that
wishes to speak I see Amy shano I think
your name is you get un
please Amy um go ahead hi thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee I
just wanted to speak I'm from
Continental Paving my name's Amy
Sharbino um everybody keeps talking
about backlog and I just want to give
you the real version of what backlog
means to US contractors in a covid world
everything's backlogged but to us this
backlog is real so obviously um we're
Paving we do large heavy Highway um site
work but when fall comes or closer to
Christmas we lay off probably say 25% of
our people just due to Paving you know
the winter what we try and do is keep as
many people as possible shuffle them to
these type projects that we're talking
about um large sites what what happened
this year is we didn't know when these
approvals were going to come so the
ability to shuffle people keep them
working was mere impossible so something
we had three to four shovel what we
would call shovel ready projects that we
knew within 30 to 60 days normally we'd
be getting a permit for and everything
would be done you know that's 20 to 80
guys that now we can employ on large
jobs well now I can't Shuffle those good
employees that I have to those locations
I can't it could be six to nine months
till I get that permit so we ended up
having to lay off more people
than normal in the winter because of
this backlog so I just I want to really
put an exclamation point on what that
backlog truly means it's not just papers
on a desk it's employees working it's
unemployment it's all those things that
New Hampshire contractors are really
feeling because of this
backlog thank any questions for Miss
sh seeing none thank you again ma'am
thank you anybody else who wish to speak
minute
Linda if you can just restate your name
and where you're
from hello can you hear me I can ma'am
go ahead okay uh my name is Linda Dion
I'm the president of the voices of
wildlife in New
Hampshire uh this bill I'm asking you to
oppose it and um it seems like this bill
has come about because of a backlog
and part of the backlog problem is
because of Co everybody's working from
home and everything was slowed down
because of covid so that's part of the
problem
um um anyway this bill will weaken the
New Hampshire Endangered Species
Act this is no time to weaken our
endanged Species
Act we need uh nature nature um I'm
talk because of pandemics and covid
we're seeing the importance of Nature
and and we should not weaken our
endanger Species Act at this time
because of everything that's going on
with our
environment I would also like to say
developers maybe maybe they could donate
to the um non-game fund so that fishing
game could hire more people to take care
of this
backlog there is that solution to hire
more people rather than we can our
Endangered Species Act and um that's all
I have sorry any
questions seeing none in the room seeing
none on Zoom thank you Miss appreciate
it I'm gonna ask Paul serson come back
online I follow question Paul are you
available for a question uh thank you Mr
chairman I'm here thank you I just want
to be clear as I'm reading the bill the
other thing is Bill do we've been
talking a lot about the word Fe but um
other thing I see I think if I
understand the bill properly I'm just
trying to uh make sure I'm clear is that
this also establishes a new fund for
fish game if I'm not mistaken that any
of these fees that may be assigned to um
to contractors or or or or developers
and that fund would go would then be a
non-aps and fund that would be funding
project to facilitate net conservation
benefit to threatened and endangered
species so not only do we have this
language about appreciable we also are
by Statute now creating a brand new fund
that would give you resources to be able
to mitigate um any you know for a net
conservation benefit overall um
endangered species is that correct uh
thank you Mr chairman yes that is
correct those sections of the bill
they're really enabling legislation uh
that enabled the department to accept
funds that are offered as is part of
Permitting processes uh remember that
here at Department of ficient game we do
not have permitting Authority nor do we
have the authority to impose uh any sort
of exaction upon anyone as part of a
permit process however this would enable
us to receive funds that have been
offered voluntarily in other permitting
processes and put them to these very
targeted uses uh and as was noted by
Senator Bradley with significant
legislative oversight uh as to how those
funds would be used for these particular
purposes thank you one followup question
one follow question for you I'm G to go
back to the word appreciably because
that's been the topic of conversation
the entire day um so on as I'm looking
at this it seems to be what what what
we're asking fishing game to do by this
bill is to do similar things we do with
when you're managing a her right the
deer her we don't tell you by Statute
how many permits they issue for hunting
licenses or how many boosts you can take
or any the other lottery type things
that that you do that as part of your
normal process to manage good herd
management and as I read this bill at
least the way I'm reading it and correct
me if I'm wrong is that we're asking to
do the same thing here is to manage
what's going on and have you put in the
rules what you're going to use to manage
that is that a a fair reading of this
bill uh it is um and understand too um
that this is a a bill that imposes a
standard not only for the Department of
Environmental Services not only for the
alteration of terrain program but our uh
relationships with all other state
departments and all other types of
programs and so yes it is giving us a
set of discretion to work with all of
those other uh applicants all of those
other agencies in order to accomplish
the statutory purpose
represent I'm glad you brought Mr
Sanderson back thank you because I had a
couple questions you know questions pop
up as we listen um so m Mr Sanderson so
um I I I did understand that there would
be um in section two and three there
would be ways uh to for funds to be
deposited with a various places in the
en ficient
game how those how those uh fees are
determined is that another thing that
would be taking place in this um very
inclusive rul making process like well
one person how how will you know that
one person gets charged $10 and another
person gets charged $10 million I
mean yes thank you for your question
representative um the actual uh
definitions and operation of a
mitigation program would not be
contained within fishing game rulemaking
because we're not the permanent
Authority we make recommendations based
upon reviews to permanent authorities
and so whether or not uh mitigation
payments are in fact required would be
part and parcel of rules that would be
adopted by other state agencies who are
administering those permit programs so
the consistency between the rules in the
various departments is something that is
the task of jel car uh so certainly as
individual departments go forward with
their permitting processes and as they
develop a mitigation program that deals
with these things that's where jel car
performs its
function I have
thank you um so I think I just heard you
say that these um uh funds would be
voluntary voluntary and so I'm just
wondering would that could that possibly
lead to any expectation on the part of a
developer that if I voluntarily pay more
I'll get my
permit uh thank you for your question
representative again as as fishing game
makes its recommendations based upon
reviews of individual projects goes back
to permitting agencies those permitting
agencies have to be very careful as they
develop and administer mitigation
programs as and mitigation programs
already exist for example the armm fund
um The Aquatic resources mitigation fund
already exists so these questions have
been asked and answered in other types
of programs where mitigation is allowed
um you have you raise a good question
but it is something that jel car is
attuned to to make sure that that sort
of criteria is there and that it's not
pertain thank
you
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr serson take one more
question uh currently many times the
state agencies and the D take a
recommendation or the advice from the
conservation town and cities
Conservation Commission or uh Regional
planning commissions is it anything is
going to
change thank you for your question
representative there's nothing in bill
that changes the local planning process
or takes away any sort of local control
over that particular planning process
that are contained in existing planning
statutes um as you go through local
planning process as you know local
conservation commissions local planning
boards local zoning boards of adjustment
all make their particular approvals
contingent upon receiv required state
permits so there is nothing here that
changes that local process or changes
the process of review in any particular
municipality nor does it impose
municipality anything further for Mr
saunderson see nothing in room seeing
nothing online thank you Mr sson there
anything else that come forward
129 seeing nothing I will close the
public hearing on Senate Bill
129 I will open the public hearing on
Senate Bill 51 and welcome into the room
uh senat Mardi U who was who was over
doing other Senate business in the in
the house and Senator if you want to go
ahead discussing Senate Bill 51
good morning everyone I'm Denise rardy I
represent District nine I was asked to
introduce this legislation by the New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association the Genesis of this bill was
a number of restaurants learning this
past summer that they needed a license
from the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department if they sell lobster that has
been processed and packaged many of them
had been buying frozen lobster meat from
Food Distributors such as sis
US Food Service or Performance Food
Group and they never realized that they
needed a license from New Hampshire Fish
and Game so I took part in a meeting
with the New Hampshire lodging and
Restaurant Association and the fish and
game department to learn more about why
are we requiring licenses for
restaurants that purchase processed and
packaged Lobster M the explanation is
that we need to license all those
involved with the harvesting processing
wholesale Distributing and eventual sale
of lobsters in order to protect the
fishery of the golf of M while I agree
with this I do not think it's necessary
an effective or efficient use of the
Department's resources to license and to
enforce the law on those restaurants
that buy and sell processed and packaged
Lobster meat from Food Distributors it's
just Overkill we already licensed all of
those involved well before the processed
and packaged meat hits the restaurant we
license the Harvester we license the
processor we license the non-resident
wholesaler and we license the resident
wholesaler under this
legislation if you buy processed and
packaged Lobster meat from a licensed
wholesaler or processor you will not
have to obtain a license from the
Department if you are a rest
however that buys live lobsters you will
still have to get a license from the New
Hampshire fishing game this bill passed
the Senate on the consent calendar I'm
asking you to recommend passage of this
Common Sense piece of legislation and
I'm happy to answer any questions that
you might have but there are folks here
from the department and the Restaurant
Association that plan to speak that
could possibly answer your questions a
lot better thank you any questions for
Sen
see none in the room none online thank
you senator for introduction to Bill
okay thank you I have to go back to my
committee
sorry next up is um Henry Bell from the
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association Henry you should be able to
unmute yourself and go ahead okay thank
you Mr chairman um and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Henry veu and I'm here on behalf of the
New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association and fortunately for you this
bill is a lot simpler than the bill you
just heard I uh I was on at 9:30 9:30
hearing and uh it was quite a complex
bill so this one is really simple I
affectionately refer to it as the
lobster roll bill um and it basically
addresses um the issue of uh processed
and pack packaged Lobster meat uh and
for restaurants that buy that meat um
right now they have to obtain a license
from fishing game and this bill uh says
and and I do want to thank Paul
Sanderson uh for um working with us on
the language uh I know the department
had uh some concerns with the original
version of the bill and the way the bill
was worded uh We've simplified it and it
basically says if you're a restaurant
you buy processed package meat from a
licensed wholesaler or processor so
we're already you know purchasing it
from someone that that's that the
department has some ability to regulate
to make sure that um the Fisheries are
protected um then you don't have to get
a license um and I want to thank Paul
for working with us on that it's a
simple Bill I'm happy to answer any
questions but it it passed unanimously
in the Senate and we're hoping for a
quick passage in the house too
thanks any questions Mr
Val seeing none in the room seeing none
online thank you
[Music]
Mr speak to see any comments Rel to this
for the Department Mr serson are you
there thank you Mr chairman I have
returned and I really have nothing to
add uh to what Senator richardi and Mr
Vu had indicated um the reason the
department had concerns is because the
entire set of regulations of lobster are
not just in New Hampshire but we also
are part of an interstate compact called
the Atlantic state marine fisheries uh
commission which administers this type
of regulations up and down the Eastern
Seaboard and so our concerns were about
being as consistent as possible uh with
our obligations to
asmfc uh we believe with this very
simple language that we will be able to
make adjustments to our Lobster rules um
not only to protect these particular
vendors but also to make sure that we
have protected marine fisheries and uh
the lobstermen who are engaged uh in
this uh from any particular negative
impacts and so uh I would like to thank
Mr Vu and the senate for their hard work
on this making the adjustments that they
did and we will proceed and make this
work thank you any questions from Mr
Sanders there being none thank you is
there anybody else in attendance that
wishes to speak if so if you raise your
you seeing none uh I will close the
51 we'll move immediately into a work
session uh we have we have plenty of
time this morning before we go lunch and
take a break um I'd like to discuss the
bills we heard this morning um and and
see if there's any consensus we can come
around to whether we protect them or not
today um and then we can also discuss we
have three bills we rained I'd like to
form a sub committee sub committees for
that
and ready for
the repres thank you Mr chair I just
have a question as the technologist here
to clarify that representative wol
online but he was out today as subtitute
in the room so we need to clarify which
one of them he will not be able to vote
on any any bills he can list all want
but can't bills because he was excused
replac all right why don't we take the
easy one up set of Bill 51 we just heard
a uh sure representative go
ahead um I'm still struggling to hear
lob talk as opposed to people calling in
I can hear people calling in loud and
clear the folks that are at the table
there uh I I can barely you're barely
audible chairman as well as uh
representative Harvey and some of the
others I don't know if it's
microphone position or what have you but
the sound here and I uh I think I see
another rep who looks like they're
struggling to get close to their
computer too to hear um I see
representative Ellis there thank you for
shaking your head uh but I think what I
I I'm I'm really struggling here to hear
me
thank
[Music]
minut
five and I I don't I don't have a soft
speaking voice so um some of the other
Representatives
speak less loudly than I so is this um
Mr chair is this our um that's your
we all right would you like
representative llan to count now
sure one 2 3 four five that's better
better how about representative Harvey
can pick it up from there because she
doesn't speak as loudly as I oh yes I do
five four three two
one loud and clear good thank you much
better thank you Roger yes yes Mr chair
this is representative Egan that's much
better thank you so representan if you
want participate in the votes because it
sounds like we might go to a vote on 51
I'll need you to um come on the zoom
link if you can find it you can gra grab
correct are you gonna are you going to
set a time for that because then I'll
make sure that I have connectivity even
if I have to think we're gonna do it
right now we're just starting that
discussion and then we're gonna jump
into a vote if everyone
agrees oh okay let me I
will stay online via phone while I get
I'll stay online L on phone while I get
myself to a better area for video and
then I'll sign off and sign back on so
going back to set Bill 51 after our
slight
on
find
what's yeah so now we just have a
sessions
are you are you dangling cookies is that
mil Sor representative stepped out as
well oh
[Music]
yeah
practice
can
yeah minut for repres we're still
waiting for representative love guys got
we waiting on representative Ean to see
if he joins we give him two minutes and
then
we'll there's representative
you'll need to unmute can you hear me
and see me we can thank you very much
the Wonder so we're talking about Senate
Bill 51 which was our least
controversial Bill the morning um and
we'll just open it up for discussion um
and see where the members TR to H is
there any concerns of this bill why we
point seeing nothing in the room
representative Howard go ahead I just I
just want to kind of clarify
um my reading of this it say you know
under 21 38 no person shall sell has not
been processed or sealed within
containers do not require
refrigeration so I'm assuming that this
license required for that process is
there also
license for selling r
that's the same thing so so again so
under current law if you sell any ler
you have to have a permit so if you sell
if you buy prepackaged from Cisco you
have to go get a license and and if it's
just prepackaged meet for lobster rules
um you have to go get a license if you
sell live lobster you also have to get a
license under this current bill because
we're only talking about um processed
and packaged Lobster meet would only
apply to um people who buy that Lobster
meat from Cisco you still have live
lobsters you still have to get a license
so restaurants that have live locks
still have to have an additional license
correct whoever they purchase those from
correct and my understanding in the
conversation is that was had to do with
establishing chain all over Lobster
there so you don't have somebody buying
Lobster from The Lobster off the boat
bypassing entire but doesn't that create
a more expensive competition
and because you're forcing the
restaurant to buy a license to buy from
him not major packaging NOP again even
if it's only if you're buying
nonprocessed lobster live lobster either
from from a large supplier or from a
lobster directly off the boat would have
to have a license either it doesn't
change it does change I will tell you
the price license is $50 that's what
we're talking I know it's just just more
government we trying to get the
government
out the license already exists we're
trying to get it out of the way for some
some any further
conversation you think we're ready to
go yeah all right so we're gonna briefly
step out of executive session I mean a
work session and move to Executive
session for uh Senate Bill 51 SL
down just one second our Clerk's got to
almost all right I'm in
every all right so we're ready I would
entertain we're moving to Executive
session on Senate Bill 51 and I would
this it's been moved a to pass on set
151 by representative scaine second
motion and seconded by representative
CL any further discussion on Senate Bill
uh Senate Bill
51 hearing none the clerk will call the
pass right representative KH yes
representative close yes representative
stain yes representative Howard
yes representative Craig
yes representative love yes
representative
mononi yes yes representative kitri yes
Smith representative Smith is absent
sorry
representative Harvey
yes representative
dville yes representative King
yes clerk votes
yes representative Egan
yes representative schliff
and Mr chair
yes the vote is 18 to Z on a vote to 18
consent we will move back into our work
uh represent represent shirli go ahead
thank you Mr chairman um Mr chairman I'm
for all the testimony I'm still
concerned about the word
acceptable and um in the letter from
attorney uh Sanderson he
mentioned um the proposed new language
is designed to move state law closer to
the EST standage used by the federal
agencies and uh and they relied on the
endangered Species Act of
1973 as well as the implementation of
new regulations that were P part of the
combined Federal Regulations passed last
year by Congress and uh this is where
where the word acceptability came into
play in what one Congress can giveth
another Congress can taketh away much
like the New Hampshire house
um I think and we heard from the uh
conservation groups and others that uh
uh this is a very good bill a much
needed Bill uh but that word of
acceptability does cause a lot of
concern and personally I'd like to see
the bill amended to remove that one word
and then I would have no problem uh
supporting the passage of the
legislation I think the word appreciably
appreciably yeah that's ites easy for
you to say I'm sorry representative
Howard thank you chairman
um you know I'm going to support this
bill because it
does uh tend to give some constitutional
landowner right back to the people but
it comes at a cost and that's the thing
I have a problem with you know every
time we turn around passing legislation
house thank you uh repres CL thankk you
Mr chair um I had the same conern
appreciably at first but um after
listening to the testimony and listening
to the the explanation from B serson uh
from fishing
game I believe that where you have
appreciably used in line seven but then
the order for fishing game to Define
aebly jeopard
in line 11 all we're doing is saying F
game now you can Define what jeopardize
means it's no different than what we do
mentioned before giving them the ability
to manage hers they can now use their
rule making to make a firm decision of
what appreci jeopardized means they can
then promulgate that decision to all
other departments that they work with in
the state so that everybody's on the
same page
and they will have
uh the ability to Define that in rules
so that if in the future the the federal
endangered Wildlife act changes they can
still redefine in rules a lot faster
than we can deal with in the legislature
what the definition of appr pre
jeopardized means it also gives them the
ability to quickly adjust their
definition it turns out that uh we have
impact to an endangered species that
didn't know about before so I think that
this is the best way to approach it it's
given flexibility fishing game to Define
used um I
actually I disagree I I have a problem
with that word appreciably um I think um
I support the concept of the bill in
that it's pushing New Hampshire fishing
gang to make rules and regulations but
um um in a timely fashion but
considering that um permits the backlog
has is is being work through um at a at
least a reasonable Pace according to
your information then I think we need to
uh take our time with this and make sure
that we get it right and I think
appreciable is one of those words that's
just um too wishy-washy so I could
support the bill without that word if it
could be amended because I do like the
concept of asking fishing game to make
the rules and regulations the only other
issue I have uh with a bill but without
the word appreciable I would support it
but I do some have some issue with the
idea of um yes SE there were divisions
of fishing game that would be reimbursed
for um um unavoidable harm but those um
reimbursements are voluntary par so you
know it's it's up to the kindness of the
heart of a developer as to whether they
are going to um Supply the money for
that harm so that that bothers me a
little bit um but it's it's more the
word appreciable so I would like to see
it amended without that word we are the
fishing game committee not we Realtors
and developer committee and so um you
know harm to fishing game is harm to
fish
uh thank you Mr chair uh I certainly
understand the concern of people who
think that appreciably is a little
subjective
however most of the language is
objective what is jeopardize what is
harm what is
minimize uh what is critical uh so
everything about this requires good
faith and I have confidence that in our
department that they will exercise this
in good faith as it's intended to
minimize uh any potential harm to any
critical or threaten
species uh and I support it as written
representative
e thank you Mr chair I do concur with
representative Harvey and representative
shirtliff in my concern about
appreciably but moreover I have a
concern that the demand that this will
put on fishing game and already
overwhelmed organization that is
underfunded by our state and if these
donations for financial
support for for services bothers me on
fishing game that they have and it's
another reason why I actually appreciate
being part of this committee is fishing
game does so much for the state yet we
minimize sorry about
that the internet is better on the road
house um the the concern I have is that
we're putting all of these demands on
this agency and now they're going to be
working on behalf of Realtors and
contractors and while I uh am a
proponent of a solid and growing economy
we have to be smart about the way that
we're going to push this agency to do
things that they're not funded for so
that's my big concern with this bill is
that we're going while this backlog I
think is some part by underfunded agency
and so I would like to look at some
other ways that
that donation is maybe more of a you
know suggested contribution or some type
of um you know if there's a bill that
the that the uh contra tractor has to
receive from fishing game to come out
and and do some of this work I know that
uh that happens sometimes with with
hunting you know the folks will fishing
game will come out and take care of of
animals for folks um and the farmer has
to um pay that fee so that's my concern
here is somewhat with the language that
gives it a vag vager and somewhat with
the financial concern that I'll put upon
uh the agency thank
you thank you represent I'm gonna go to
people who haven't spoken first and then
we'll come back to second second word um
do want to make one comment to that
question though either way ficient game
is doing this is that by the court order
they're obligated to review every aot
permit um that goes to De because of the
court order the court case that went
through so whether we pass this bill or
don't pass this bill they still have the
obligation so those 81 permits they had
backlogged in March um we're still going
to they're still going to grow um I just
happened to take a big peek at our
revenues because because it driven by
the rep tax our real estate transfer tax
and we're up 32% so development is
happening and those permits and fishing
gain are going to continue and the
question is whether we give them the
authority of managing and how we make
the managing whether we give them a
funding source that's kind of what this
bill is doing but just understand that
while we can we can talk about the fact
that we're not the you know the housing
and development program we also have to
recognize the fact that they are in fact
have to do this already by the by the
court ORD so we have to manage how would
best how best manage that process
because they have to um represent the
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman I am
convinced after hearing all the
testimony from the expert especially Mr
sers said that nothing will change from
the local like our planning for the
Conservation Commission and the uh
Regional Planning Commission that uh
they will have their say or their
recommendation to the dees or other
state agencies I'm also convinced that
nothing will change in my district where
we uh preserve our piping flers and
other fees in our seel especially our
pristine um um um 16 to 20 mile sea
coost in our state so I will vote for
this bill and I also vote for this bill
at the SCH house anybody else for
representative thank you Mr
chair to with representative how you
know everything has a
price you know the word
litigation it gives
gives a like to stand on
judg could be looking at a a 10 acre
development uh that has a Acres around
affecting have to
beated project to be delayed a cost
developers you know and I I do have
concern too represent mentioned about
the funding for this he's
take and I don't have the I don't have
how much man
power but without this
with us passing this wouldn't that um
you know I know in the state
constitution we can't uh do an unfunded
mandate would be mandating fishing game
to do this and therefore that be it
should be
language so on the unfunded mandate that
only relative to towns and cities we
can't pass down town C we think State
agen whatever we want but relative to
towns and cities
28a is Rel pass cost by passing stat
AG represent M you had your hand go
ahead
sir uh thank you Mr chairman pleasure to
be with you folks and I'll speak as a
practitioner the um the there was a lot
of talk on backlog and what that's
causing the business and so forth but
the problem really started with a rule
change in Department of Environmental
Services that caused all all of these
applications to go to fishing game when
it was only select that were causing or
would cause harm too so the problem
really started with Dees and uh we heard
some uh we heard some testimony that
some folks uh thought that the uh impact
the Fallout would not be what it was but
it turned out to be that um this this
appears from what I'm hearing from the
commissioner
uh will correct that will allow them to
move forward um I stand in support of
trouble
you thank you Mr
chairman uh while we're thinking about
loading work on somebody what about our
court
system secondly uh thing called
paralysis by analysis at some point
human judgment has to come in I think we
are making a lot of good steps in this
in
anybody else who hasn't spoken
yet thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
follow up because some conversation came
up around the term voluntary that was
used by Mr Sanderson and I was wondering
if the chair would allow Mr Sanderson
come back on for a clarification
question I believe that one of the
parties here in the room whether be me
or one of the others is
misunderstanding voluntary I don't
believe that that was voluntary from a
land owner or a builder it was voluntary
from the permitting agency as in they
could pass along part of the permitting
prices and fees that they put on the
building site and so Dees could
voluntarily pass that along game or
whatever agency was working I'd like to
get clarification on that I also would
like to emphasize that I don't think
this is increasing workload on F game
they have to do it now what I heard from
Paul Sanderson it would actually
decrease their workload because they
have to do every permit now and this
would allow them to now go back to where
they don't have to handle every single
permit that that has potential
impact unless this objection in the
committee I will allow Mr sers come back
and talk to the question that voluntary
payment to get clarification around what
that means Mr Sanders are you there yes
I am thank you Mr chairman
um if I could to correct any sort of
misunderstanding from my comments let me
make a couple of points once again uh
fish and game as we go through this
process we make recommendations to other
permitting agencies we have no authority
to impose any sort of exaction upon any
particular uh applicant or Pere however
as it moves over to the permitting
agency permitting agency through its
particular program may have the ability
to impose such a fee or such an exaction
in accordance with rules or other
procedures that they may
adopt okay so it is also possible for uh
a particular applicant to make a
voluntary contribution to fishing game
that is the voluntary nature of what an
applicant may do so let me please just
make the distinction between these
fishing game cannot require an exaction
a permitting agency through the adoption
of rules and other procedures could
require an exaction any applicant is
free to make a voluntary payment based
upon their own
determination if I can get those three
job thank you I think that made this
clear as much
um don't use the word volunt Paul I'm
gonna rephrase because I'm a simple guy
I like simple words so what it sounds
like to me what you said was because
you're not the permitting agency and
Dees is the permitting agencies of an
aot authorization of of dinin um that uh
for the for the change of terrain the um
Dees could establish rules that would
create some some fee structure that
would require fees for Mitigation Of of
habitat um however you can't require
that however that doesn't stop any um uh
contractor developer from from putting
funds in because having mitigation
issues is that correct all of those are
correct statements Mr chair thank you
um any other questions for Paul while
goe thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Sanderson I'm just trying to like keep
track of of of how this works so at the
current time after the Supreme Court
case all application per for permits
have to go through fishing game what
happened
um to
those how can I say this if so under
this bill the executive director
would use his rul making Authority or
whatever to decide if a project
appreciably
[Music]
um causes problems to the wildlife
habitat um and I guess his
recommendation would then be fish and
games recommendation that would go to
the permitting agency is that do I have
that right so far yes you do um now I
just want to make one small correction
when you say that all particular uh
applicants for all particular permits
now have to come to fish and game that's
only true for the alteration of terrain
permits and that's only because of the
rule that several Representatives have
referred to that was adopted by
Department of Environmental Services in
response to the Supreme Court case that
affected that program there again we
deal with many different departments we
deal with other types of permits and so
it is the requirement for all right now
is limited to the alteration of terrain
program now moving on to your next point
which is when we do receive a review and
undertake a review that results and
recommendations that we make back to the
permitting agency they are
recommendations because we are not the
regul at Authority we're not the
permitting
agency the regulatory agency the
permitting agency takes that information
in and in general will in incorporate
that into the permits that they do in
fact issue to
applicants have followup
follow in your esteemed opinion how
would this bill reduce or prevent the
existing
backlog okay I I don't know how esteemed
the opinion is but um in any event what
is actually happening in the dis between
our agencies is what has been reported
to you that we are going back to the
system where the information that is
being sent over to us is based upon uh
information from the natural heritage
database instead of having every single
alteration of terrain permit come to our
agency for review it would be those that
do have positive information coming from
the nhb database the so-called nhb hits
you heard from several testimony several
people who gave you testimony this
morning that will
temporarily cause the uh reduction in
the amount of reviews that we conduct
and will reduce the amount of time in
backlog however as we also reported to
you and as you've heard the general
economic uh condition that is out there
is increasing the number of uh projects
that are being proposed increasing the
number of permits that are likely to be
filed and that will increase again the
number of permits uh and other questions
that will come to us for review that's
why we're trying to send the information
to you that suggests the current efforts
that we're taking to manage are that
current efforts temporary not the
solution thank you Mr chair so um I just
want to pick up and make sure that I
heard uh representative the flame
statement correctly so in his rulemaking
authority the the executive director
would have sole authority to decide
which permits go forward to the
permitting or um agency um and that his
his decision
is then considered New Hampshire Fish
Games decision did did representative of
flame say that correctly or did
thank you representative for your
question not quite accurate okay and
again remember we work with many
different agencies on many different
programs and so therefore for example
working with the Department of
Transportation we enter into a
memorandum of agreement or a memorandum
of understanding with the assistance of
the Attorney General's office to control
the relationship between our two
departments okay on issues of that type
and so therefore it's not solely within
the rulemaking authority of the
executive director of the fish and game
department that would also be true for
Department of Natural and cultural
resources what we what we are talking
about here is working cooperatively with
the Department of Environmental Services
and the alteration of terrain program
that's why we conducted our request for
comment in advance of Ru making jointly
so that as we try to adjust these two
aspects of program the aot program and
our response to the aot program the two
departments are working together such
that both sets of rules will go to Jael
car on a consistent schedule and that we
will work cooperatively to try to manage
our problem and try to manage our effort
to more quickly respond to these
requests for
information you know I think the more I
listen to
testimony I'm still confused I'm just
confused on a higher level so let me see
if I can clear one thing up for Paul
maybe having served on job card now my
third term um if you don't understand
what the rule making it's not like the
commission just writes a rule and says
okay this is the new rule go do it um
that has an entire process behind it
that has public hearings and public
input um and then when they're all done
doing their public hearings and public
input and they come out with an adjusted
uh rule that rule then goes in front of
jard joint legislative commit
administrative rules who then reviews
the rule again and makes recommendations
and and considerations for adjustments
to that no I that's part I guess so so
understand well I'm not sure everybody
does I know as a freshman I had no idea
what they put me on I'm pretty sure
speaker I think it
was was Jas was eming me for something
put but um just I just want to make sure
fresh understand what what that rule
process looks like it's not just one
person sitting in a room creating a new
rule and making it a refollow state so
there is a significant amount of public
input public comment process as well as
a length of time because a period of
time
statutory requirements of how long rules
have to be open the public comment and
all that so there's a pretty significant
process for that so I guess this is
where I go back to with you know again
with the only word we seem really
focusing on is the word appreciably here
well I moved past that yeah well for me
so my question is um I I just want to
know who at New Hampshire fishing gang
when there's been one of these requests
for permit one of these backlogged
requests who at fishing game reviews it
and decides that it is um it is harmful
or not harmful and should move forward
to whatever the next steps are who at
fishing game makes that
determination so Paul I know we heard
that question you want to answer so the
question comes down to is is there a
biologist or who's looking at these aot
um permits requests that are coming
through right now in your agency and
how's that determination made regarding
the appreciably jeopardized standard
thank you yes I did hear the question
the answer to that is this referral
comes over to our Wildlife division it
is then specifically delegated to the
non-game program the supervisor of the
non-game program works with one
full-time wildlife
biologist and one uh halftime dedicated
to this particular program and those
three individuals work together to to
take a look at the specifics of the
individual case and make a determination
of the level of review that is required
to provide recommendations in that
individual case so it is the wildlife
Division and non-game program with those
three specific employees who make the
determination and communicate back to
the permitting agency or the other state
agency so the executive director has
nothing to do with it well uh we all
work for the executive
any further
questions wanted
to further potential clarification on
this where the executive director comes
in is is in kicking off the rul making
process to define the definition of
appreci jeopardize the continued
existence of such species in the ru
making which essentially is setting the
bar that fish game will measure against
the biologists make the determin
of whether that bar has been reached or
roached or whether they're well within
bounds of that correct Paul uh yes all
all of our Authority within fishing game
flows through the uh executive director
um I am the person who actually drafts
these in cooperation with our other
staff but I don't actually attempt to
promulgate a rule without the permission
of the executive director um the exact
criteria that may be contained in there
is reviewed by the executive director
before we file formal rulemaking and go
through the process in Jael car the
representative Lang describe to you um
so again all of our authorities flow
else thank you Paul so we're back to
General discussion on the bill as as it
stands um again you know my position is
that you know this is to a certain
extent build trust you know whether we
trust the wildlife group the three
employees we just spoke about as they
review this and and I'm sure they're
going to have input into what this word
appreciably jeopardize means um in that
phrase um in the development of rules
and whether we trust that bill they'll
manage this process to do this process
or whether we think the legislative Au
put that in I'm not a fan of absolutes
personally you know when you take out
that word appreciable it becomes an
absolute statement which I think means
we have absolute LW um going forward um
and and the appreciable um gives gives
the wiggle room that that will allow
fishing game to properly manage these
this this aot process that they've been
thrust into by rule for the and the
court order so um that's my take on I'm
going to support the bill as it's
written I think that that I trust
fishing game to and the wildlife group
to properly Define only thing I don't
like about this bill is a chicken
problem we have we can't create the rule
until we pass the law can't create the
law until we pass the rule what do we do
right and so I'm going to error on the
side of trust and Trust fishing game and
say that I I I I I having been involved
in the ja like I said for the last three
terms I trust their process they take
significant input from public um they
adjust their rules based on public input
and I think that they can better Define
what appreciably jeopardized means that
weend in
our so that
so that being said what I think we're
going to do is I'm going to take um
we're GNA go into recess for 20 minutes
we'll come back at
11:30 um and we'll allow for some brief
caues so I'm gonna ask stop the the
meeting and we'll ask the Republicans to
stay in the room um we step out for 10
minutes and then we'll step out of the
room do the room for 10 minutes um and
allow you to just have a conversation we
come back to 11:30 to decide what we
want to do whether want time to go get
an amendment or not and then we
de sound reasonable to everybody yes
great so we'll be in recess for um 20
minutes we're back at 11:30 and we will
um have a caucus Republican caucus right
now for next 10 minutes chairman Lange
yes um I'm sorry to interrupt I just
wanted to let you know that the meeting
will technically continue you can mute
the um video and the
audio um and I'll do a share screen that
says um how long the committee will be
in recess great thank you thank you
representative um if the Republican
Representatives want to give my phone a
call at
63566 9802 I should be able to get two
or three is on my phone I can throw you
hear can I ask for that number again Mr
9802 980 what sir
you
for
hey Larry hi
okay sent an email saying just I'd
follow Katherine's lead but I didn't
think an amendment was necessary hey
other people were on oh we Have No
Secrets I I I can't hear any hardly
anybody in the
lob thank you uh Roger for speaking up I
couldn't hear either and
bad thank you thank you Donna for
leaning in because I knew you were doing
what I was trying to do in the
Stream
jeez I didn't hear I didn't hear love at
all and I could barely hear
Howard yeah it was tough yeah it was I
could hear when Tim backs away from the
him
how about you Mark can you hear
everything
wow well after they adjusted the
microphones of the sound it was okay
yeah and then it dropped back down some
yeah
I sent a text to Katherine I don't know
if she got it so did
timc what about me can you hear in
yellow can you hear stuff from L pretty
clear I can you're you're actually I
have to turn my audio down when you talk
because you're loud and everybody else
is low and I have to turn my audio up so
I agree with you that it's a little low
in the room but you're probably having
more of a issue with it than me he's the
death man shouting
yeah more issue than I is the correct
Engish I think
there thank you I I I failed to correct
inaccuracy
all right guys just couple minutes for
everybody to take their seat someone's
on just couple minutes everybody in
their
seat
[Music]
how's
thisit all right looks like we have
everybody back um we will move we'll
stay in work session for just one minute
I believe we're probably at a point
where we're gonna just take a vote a
motion on this bill unless anybody has
offer all right did you define that word
appreciable that you just used sure
answer
um all right so we will move into
executive session I recognize represent
for purposes of a motion I'd like to
move
OTP on SP 129 it's been moved by
representative Spain ought to pass by on
set Bill
129 uh representative MRI I second that
it's been seconded by representative
mckitrick there any further discussion
129 there being none we'll go to a roll
call
vote
representative KH yes representative
post yes representative Spain yes
representative Howard yes representative
Craig
yes representative love
yes representative Mark
Boni
yes representative kitridge yes
representative dsty
yes representa Smith is absent
no Representative laflam no
Representative dville no representative
King NOP the clerk votes no
representative Egan no Representative
shirtliff no representative Ellis
vote Mr
chair yes thank you the vote is 10 to8
on a vote to 10 to8 on a motion of V to
pass uh the the bill passes Minority
Report who's going to be responsible for
so representative Hardy minity
reportes the majority report um any of
the other
discussion great we move out of
executive session so um we used to have
sheets or something that Minority
reports so regarding the minority
majority reports you just type it up and
send it to representative re as the
clerk she'll get she'll get yours and
and rep expain together phone over me
for final approval and then I'll send it
off to the I'll send it off to the
that
um next end of the
week no great rush I don't think it'll
be in the house ready session
going
on
um great uh talking about this afternoon
so we have two provisions and I meant to
pull up C Bill 46 because I could
remember the second provision we had um
so at one o'clock over in rrmg they have
Senate Bill
146 um Senate Bill 146 is omnus Bill
coming out of the Senate um that bill
has one provision that belongs
environment n two Provisions that belong
to fish of gain and two Provisions that
belong actually to
rrd um and so what we're going to do is
myself representative Spain
representative Reed are going to go over
into the rrd room the committee chair
there is going to turn the meeting over
to me when we talk about those two um uh
issues those two items number three and
number five um in the committee I'll
manage the committee meeting while we
while that goes on we're going to we're
going to hopefully change this into a
zoom so you'll zoom into the meeting as
as a participant in the meeting um and
be able to ask questions when we get
there so uh when we're done with that
hearing on those two Provisions um we
will uh come back to this room and
reopen our meeting and that work session
we'll take a vote on those two
Provisions the straw pole vote it's
non-binding to anybody but it's
basically our recommendation our R&D on
those two Provisions do we think you
should keep it and pass it do you think
you should put it out of the bill
because it needs pull it out of the bill
because it needs more work um and then
r& will make their the end ours is just
a recommendation has no binding effect
on them at all chess gives them a
recommendation of the fishing game
committee what we think of those two
positions if we think it needs more work
um they may choose to just strike it and
have somebody resit a bill next year um
we like the idea but we just think that
the bill is not ready for time for that
section um they can they'll put an
amendment in strike it or they'll leave
it into
[Music]
understand maybe I missed I was writing
a note to myself I don't write things
down I forget um so just you and
represent this three us can go in so
it's G be my myself the technologist on
the question okay we'll go in we'll go
in and listen the rest of you'll be on
Zoom you'll be able when we get to the
point of asking questions of witnesses
I'll recognize the room and anybody in
the room and and representative AB will
kind of help sort who's uh up up next to
speak the room we will all have the
opportunity we all be able to ask any
questions on any those on the two
Provisions we'll take them one at a time
the order though that was explained to
me is we're going to take questions to
people in that Rd room first on the
bills then we're going to ask questions
get questions from this room and then go
to the public if they have so it' be in
that order or the the R&D rep we're are
we doing that on each section we're
doing two sections we're doing on each
section
wites ask that question we'll have
witnesses and witnesses there be able to
ask questions and then we're all done
with those three sections we'll come
back to this room take a go into work
session take a straw pull and a
non-binding vment but after our sections
are done not after our two notna wait
till the whole thing done no just our
two thank you representative Ean go
ahead so just clarify we'll be on this
same Zoom link for that those
discussions this afternoon NOP you'll
have to disconnect from this Zoom well
if you're if you're remote you can just
disconnect from this Zoom link and join
go over to the house page and grab the
zoom link over there um and just from
there
foration resources and
development and
then so if you're remote you should join
remotely that time again was 1M yep 1 pm
so if you're remote you should go over
to the Rd page grab the zoom link off of
there um if you're in the room you'll be
able to use the existing room here and
use the microphone here so um thank you
all but if they if they get that Sim
link they only we can promote it okay
right they can raise their hand and
questions how do we get i'll we'll
disconnect that when and start a new
[Music]
session we'll take care of it before we
leave
on
the represent Shir go ahead sir thank
you Mr chairman Mr chairman I've got to
leave for another meeting this afternoon
so I won't be back at one o'clock but
before I go I do want to thank you for
the wonderful job you did in uh
conducting these hearings and and thank
the whole committee for their uh their
outstanding performance as well so thank
you all thank represent certainly if I
appreciate the compliment I'll tell you
I learned it all from you
speak that's a bit of blinding but I
like
it thank you all right guys so we'll
stand in recess for lunch we'll come
back here around I'll be here for 12:55
to get that set up and then at one
o'clock we'll be in the the three of us
will be in the rid room we go from there
guys representative
Lang
yes just to clarify I was wondering um
so our meeting will need to continue for
streaming purposes um so we can let the
public who tries to uh tune in kind of
know when you guys are coming back do
you have an approximate time when when
fishing game will
reconvene I don't I think we'll probably
be back I I don't anticipate more than
an hour but I don't know how many
witnesses they have I haven't seen the
sheet for R&D to see how many people are
testifying on sections three and five
okay so um do you think it's okay if I
if I if I post two clock right now or do
you want you just say roughly roughly
okay and then I'll pop down and come
work with you guys on the equipment
I I just looked their Facebook page said
they
open
call
to
con
Alice
Roger I best the
best as as
lighting I'll have you know that
plant-based
beer wine is all plant-based it is all
plant-based and there's a cat finally
Roger has a cat did not he was here in
the
room Roger's cat is gonna give ride that
something was veg if I have to buy
special
fear wonder if I was a vegan if I have
to
special no um for for a long time
Guinness Stout was not
vegan because they had fish
bladders okay they no longer use fish
bladders drinking them they clarify beer
it actually pulls the yeast down out of
disgusting it's really delicious though
I want to know who who job it was to hey
Patty we be needing some more fish
letters
right all right so I'm going to convene
our work session uh
2011 um so you guys heard the um
testimony on Senate Bill 146 our goal
for today at the end of this work
session just to a non-binding vote that
we could give to uh and recommendations
that we could give to the R&D committee
who has to EXA this bill permanently and
deal with it I'll give my two cents
worth and I think you probably heard my
testimonies the first one in on section
three that we have to change that one
word from emergency order to executive
order because you can't do an emergency
order unless you have a state of
emergency and yet I think the idea was
to allow the governor to act quickly on
something using executive order powers
and then later follow up with statute if
we need to but because of the timing of
that
process Sor no that process is already
Serv so 141c does have some sections in
there relative to human diseases but it
wouldn't stop the importation
537 35 something under the
DHS they can you know they can
createorder right you know for emergency
right they create a declaration of
Public Health
not a governorate emergency but this the
language in the bills particular talks
about the governor and emergency and ex
it says emergency order but I think it
should say executive order and it just
allows the governor to write an
executive order saying you can't bring
in xyc fish because of this known
pandemic right and that stop the
importation of that animal into the
state so on section three that was only
change I have that I would like to see
really seems to me this ought to be an
agriculture issue inad fish I made that
comment when I was in there yeah it's
one of those weird it's animals right so
you you wild life and then you got
domesticated animals and how you manage
the to I I really want to know who's
selling monkeys and rats for and bats
for food exactly it does say
specifically consp for
consumption I see like mention
esgo I can see somebody selling that
live it's the best way to get it is
fresh or um you know freshwater crawfish
that we do have in New Hampshire might
be
CAU don't C but he said
cover and did it specify food for human
consumption it says for human
consumption
okay I don't
think I believe that the sale of wild
animals is prohibited in New Hampshire
you can't go out and catch rainbow trout
and sell you you can't go and sell your
deer no you can't sell your deer there's
a difference between an animal you've
tagged like a deer or a bear or if
you're a restaurant I believe you can go
out and catch fresh rainbow truck in
your restaurant Old really yeah so okay
but you cannot go out Sho deer and then
serve that deer in your restaurant and
sell it you have to have a give it away
you have to have a tag for the for the
deer so it's different if it's if it's
tagged got it's controlled tagged animal
moose deer
turkey so um I forget now represent
Love's comment about well you know's
eating rats and monkeys right now it's
my understanding that this is
also maybe a preventative bill for
something that might
down the road future I definitely think
this a future looking not What's happen
that you know knows what people
in 20 to 30 years who would have thought
P what what Peng where the pic
came
p
asan anybody else on section three of
any changes think we should recommend or
not recommend and are we okay with the
bill as it goes we STI a straw Point
straw poll all those in favor of the
bill with the one recommendation of
changing it from emergency to Executive
just signify by raising your
hand there anybody
oppose I don't see anyos so the
recommendation on section three to the
R&D Comm L where you need to type um is
to recommend passage with one language
change and that is the replacement of
executive three part just part three
we'll do them each separately and we'll
make recommendations on each part um so
having uh taking a straw poll and
everybody being the affirmative on 18 to
zero I'm not sure how many you actually
have but something to zero V
um with the quum present um we're going
to recommend section three go forward
with the one language change moving on
to section five this is the one that
deals with derel cleanup fund der
fishing equipment and gear cleanup fund
and the creation and the fees associated
with that um again I I my only comment
is I want to get rid of the language
that says um fishing for energy um which
I just seems like a foolish line that's
in there and it's open for all kinds of
misinterpretation um I think the name of
the fund should be nothing more than um
der yeah should be should be derc
fishing gear and Coastal cleanup fun and
that's it there's nice and clean yes so
if if we did that I mean he he explained
that you put that word in there because
there was one
specific uh fund that has that name and
possibly this money could go into that
fund so if we took that name out and
just Leed the Leed it Leed it left it um
broader derel fishing funds could it
still go into that one that is named so
because we're not changed down below it
talks about what the fund could be used
for and and this is where I would go to
the fishing there is a fishing for
energy um program a I think it's always
a bad idea to name a state program after
a federal program so then you never no
idea which one you're really talking
about the programs so it's an oia not
oia Nao
whatever
yep um program that deals with they'll
put out dumpsters basically allow
fishermen to put stuff in a federal
funded program at this point that's
named fishing so I'd rather not have
state fund and our name the same but in
the bill itself it says that the monies
for this fund shall be uh used and uh
used establish shall be used establish
and support new and existing programs to
retrieve and dispose of der fishing gear
to conduct periodic Coastal cleanup
programs for the removal of derc fishing
gear Marine trash and to support
recycling efforts for fishing year other
Marine trash so I think under that last
section the recycling program which is
what this is this is it covers what they
want not hav't put the name in the fund
which is I think just confusing well and
also you said it it says
existing programs and so this is a
program that is already existing so it
could be um by and and and by keeping
the name broad then possibly there may
be other things that uh would right
again comment right so again I know that
sebr and Hampton Beach have Beach clean
right so they could in theory apply for
a rant from fishing game now to help
offset some of the cost
Town those beaches clean up beach
cleanups and stuff that goes on same
with the great B right so Shore areas in
g day that have Beach that have th Stu
washing up cleaning and rehabilitating
beaches yeah sometimes when you get
specific like well this wasn't in the B
this
wasn't okay so that's all I just think
that having the two names is confusing I
think we strike it makes the bill more
clean very Define this is about for
cleaning beaches up and collecting their
here um when you add the word energy you
start getting people go crazy sometimes
about energy so um I think just a clear
language I just thank you Mr chairman I
just want to let all the members know
that our town DPW cleans up the beach
every time we have the beach storm lot
of those equipments and everything comes
to our beach and our C up also in order
just for everyone's knowledge that the Y
Fisher who the land they use thece
taxpayer donate their land I mean lease
that land for
$1 so we doing our part funding this you
tax just clarify something
concept how much of this abandoned
tackle do to strong
Rel it's depending it's lot so this
isn't because guys
just
right is there anything else in section
five other than my recommendation of
striking that one language and renaming
the fund and striking everywhere in the
bill that says the name of that
fund that fishing BR represents yeah I
still have a problem with the timing
issue um just because I think for
existing fisherman saying okay we'll
give you credit you helped with the
clean up last year was great but if
you're a new fisherman you come into the
program you buy your license there's
nothing here that says you can get the
discount you didn't participate so the
first time fisherman that's joining it I
think it's going to end up paying for it
even if they want to participate so I
would I would love to see them add in
this section that's repeated everywhere
where it says any person who satis fact
really demonstrates to the executive
director that he or she is participating
in a coastal cleanup program shall not
be required to pay the Ser charge I'd
like to see it say or shall be offered a
credit on the subsequent sub subsequent
years fishing
license for their participation just so
that it says you know you'll get a
credit next year for what you did this
year I I understand the timing issue is
is tricky although call was very Mr
serson was very adamant that that would
be ironed at through the rules and so
forth which we gave them a lot of leway
this morning on um
but I think what you're saying is
happens
automatically so you pay for your
license this year you don't get the
credit because you're a first time issu
then you participate in the program so
you get that credit then the second year
on your license because you participated
in the program in between the two
licenses you're right maybe what I was
thinking would have been rebated back to
you whatti so that you didn't you get
back this year while you're on the
license but um that I suppose would be
an ongoing repeate exactly forget
it any other the cost of these licenses
are a limited a limited commercial
license is $400 a regular commercial
license $600 I'm pretty sure they're not
into word what if you have so a first
that would allow them to not pay the
first year and then continue going
forward on on good faith and if they
don't anticipate the first
year that would probably clear up the
timing it's
the but it's the same difference you're
either getting your your your discount
the first year or you're getting it the
second year no he's saying any first
time you don't pay it the first year but
going forward if you didn't participate
that first year you don't get the
discount the second year so um you know
how we just talked about the fact that
you might pay for it the first year but
if you did the clean up then your next
year you get it free well this would say
now you've got the two years free you
don't pay it the first year if you
participate you get the second year free
as
well thank you Mr chairman um yeah I
agree with you about cleaning up the
title of the bill because the blurb
doesn't include the uh the part that
you'd like to excise I think that would
be
consistent secondly uh I was just
curious I I well Cons considering the
point that was just discussed the direct
the director has has
discretion you know as to when it's
going to be applied yeah you know I
think we can trust the guy to use some
common sense I hope so but that's you
know uh and finally uh what is this
about scallop scallop divers so there's
an amendment that was put in that we
have very few um scallop and urchin
feed so I'm not sure but it was a deal
that was worked out between fishing game
the commercial Fishman and and Senator
and everybody seems to be in agreement
that because I'm pretty sure you know
free driving scal doesn't have much in
the way of gear that he doesn't wear and
bring
home no I was just going to say that
commercial scallop fishing you're
dragging the water you're not actually
out there trying to Pi them
up thank you I just want to make sure
that when we say ler life you should
always mention that commercial ler life
otherwise it's not going to go anywhere
people confused you know you know all
the general public and they say that our
Lobster I mean the license is going up
when legat went up on lober license
should say commercial lober license and
also just one
second also uh when a commercial
fisherman new fisherman applies for a
license he or she willing to pay
$400 and knowing that they're going to
make money and they're not making for
pleasure they they commercial F if they
have to pay $10 more or $15 more you
know it's it's normal you
know that's all I have to
say
comment
this get the commercial Lobster license
we just de the lobster bill would this
have to be paid as a surra to everyone
who buys the commercial Lobster license
including the guy selling the life in
the grocery store who's not going out
there clean up he's not actually doing
any active lobster
fishing he's just buying the
license
must a different license a differenter
it's not it's not for lobster harvesting
it's for lobster sales sales or you know
what is it called all right so rain
is on remote that has a question they'd
like to add
processing
I just wanted to add to representative
Spain's question there yeah I can tell
you that the supermarket has Lobster
license but we can't go lobster right so
license be fun all right so so right now
the recommendation would be to just to
accept the bill as it's written with the
name change of the fund to strike that
uh fishing for energy out of the out of
everywhere in the so it's just a
der um the derel fishing gear and
Coastal cleanup
fund does that sound good anybody want
to add that no I'm voting okay she
already there all those in favor of that
raising your hand all those
opposed great um last thing we have to
quickly discussed I have I'm my little
cheat um is we have three bills we
retained I'm going to form form three
subcommittees um the to hear those three
retain bills we have to have the report
out of the subcommittees by no later
than say September 1st so that we have
about a month two months I can schedule
a full Committee hearing on once we get
the subcomittee report and um and then
we'll have to act on it to have a report
to the house by I think it's November
1st we have to have the reporting and
then we'll vote on the actual bills at
that point uh that have been retained
and that'll be a recommendation going
for the first meeting in January for
next year so we have House Bill 118
which is relative Fishing Game
Commission I'm and the first name person
is going to be the chair uh
representative KH representative Spain
representative Howard representative
Reed and representative
Ox on relative the trout House Bill 241
is going to be representative con
representative Spain representative Reed
and on House Bill 490 committing the use
of live action game prft be
representative con uh
representative Howard and representative
Ox those be the members of the
Committees um the chairman will of the
subcommittees will will work with the
members on the committee to schedule
that and I'll work with him to make sure
he understands that process um we'll
have the subomi set up for sometime over
the summer um or anytime we can start on
it to get it out of the way um just
can't vote on any Bill until September
um we're holding bills just in case we
want to tag something on to if we
execute then we're stop for done we our
votes taken and so if something comes up
between now and then we need a bill to
append something to we want to keep
these bills in play until SE so October
we can vote out in October get the
committee report to the house for
November 1st and it'll be in the
calendar
for just one question because everybody
here question is when
appropriate time buttee me to have our
first meeting and then we go on but
important to have that
time I would look after our next house
session the next house session I think
is be sometime early June maybe the end
of May I'm not
sure um exactly but I would look at you
know either late just starting around
July one after
that
meeting and again talk to Comm M you can
meet whenever you
want we need notice but you want to meet
next week we can make that happen your
committee members start a little email
change find out what works for them and
then you want to meet in June that's
fine
paid anything else to come before the
adjourn